All right, let's bring out our final contestant.
It's Traci.
Hi, Traci.
(crowd cheering)
(applause)
Hi, Traci.
Okay, Traci, we have been blown away
by the talent so far.
So where are you from?
Well, I'm Traci Martin.
I'm from West Point, Georgia.
And I'm the mom of three crazy kids.
And my talent is walking on my hands
while saying the alphabet backwards.
That old thing.
Which is kind of random.
So this is two skills I've always been able to do.
But the way it came together was, when I had... (laughs)
I want know the story.
When you could do two things and thought,
"What if I did them at the same time?"
When my kids were in middle school, we had 4-H camp
that was always a chaperone for on these field trips.
And so they'd have talent shows and the kids would say,
"We want the parents to be in the talent show."
So I would come out and say, "I'm from a planet where
everything is backwards and upside down,
And my name is Icart" Which is Traci spelled backwards.
And then I'd do my little trick.
So honestly, the only people that have seen this
fare seventh and eighth graders
Okay.
In the woods.
I mean, this is a hidden talent.
I love it.
This is all about hidden talent.
Yes, and this is what we call an exclusive.
You're not gonna see this anywhere
but the Drew Barrymore show, okay?
Well, I'm really excited to see it, Traci.
All right, here we go.
Z Y X W V U T S R Q P O N M L K J I H G F E D C B A.
Now I know it, Z2A, Drew Barrymore show.
(crowd cheers)
(applause)
I love it, Traci!
It's so fun.
Thank you, Traci, so much.
I love that talent.
Thank you so much.
Why don't you guys all come up here
and it's time to declare a winner.
One at a time we'll hold up our paddles with a vote,
but of course you're all winners in our eyes and I,
gosh, oh gosh, this is just, oh God.
Is there something with everyone?
I guess I'll go here.
It's so hard, 'cause I love everybody.
I hate this.
(applause)
Wow, all so good.
I think the one that I'm the most impressed by
'cause I wanna be able to do it and I think it's
really good cardio.
(crowd cheering)
(applause)
I know, maybe everyone will get a vote.
You're the tiebreaker.
I could vote for any of you, you know?
You all wowed us, and so I'm gonna say
at the end of the day, just because of the pure energy,
I'm gonna go with Bernadette.
(crowd cheering)
(applause)
I'm like, here's my real vote.
Yeah, I agree.
Everybody.
Yes.
I'm not good at this 'cause I just enjoy
what all of you do, and thank you so much
for coming here today and having fun with us.
(crowd cheering)
(applause)
And thank you to Ross and Seth Rudetsky.
Thank you so much for coming here and doing this.
I had a great time.
(crowd cheering)
(applause)
Be sure to catch Seth on Stars in the House
which benefits the actors fund.
And you've been so good and so supportive of them.
Love the actors.
If people don't know, the actors fund is for anybody
in the arts, actors, singers, dancers, everybody backstage,
in front, anyone can go to theactorsfund.org
and get help paying their rent, paying their medical bills.
So if you know any artists, tell them.
Yes, thank you, Seth, very much.
And check out his website to see where he's performing next!
(upbeat music)